oh I think interact still holds the
crown for best uploads this upload speed
um here's got the worst upload speed me
anyone is ripe also inject doing
something shifty over there that's very
suspicious but fastest downloads um this
is still did anyone beat Connie's 2.78
anyone it's pretty good Oh Samuel just
sneaks in with that team was so a curse
ah now I came would you all stop testing
for a second and look up okay because
this is now this is the useful part to
us tell me why are there is such
discrepancies between all the numbers
all of the numbers really how come it's
not consistent any takers okay I get
number one for instance I know for a
fact that Jack where is it Jack took one
of his results from San Francisco okay
which accounts for his monstrously large
ping ok 316 that's all that's a very
large Pig okay by the way just on ping
you may have noticed some of the
websites they use a slightly different
word for it they use the word latency
okay which is really referring to the
same thing it's it's sort of the formal
word that is what lag means right how
long is there what kind of wait is there
between sending and response call and
echo if you like now came back here what
anyway um number one location what else
what are the differences are there
surely a location I mean most of you
guys are on the same we're not this one
is not sped test this one's on either
nice okay apart from that the rest of us
are on the same location so why the big
differences
other people ah good sign remember Shh I
keep on making this analogy to
communication systems and traffic right
like cars like we go through different
paths some parts are faster some are
slower sometimes there's just an
accident and everything stuck in a city
rail or whatever okay so all of these
are going to be subject to how much
traffic is on the network and right now
all of you guys are causing traffic for
each other okay and in fact if we did
this half the school the traffic would
be different again and if we did a nine
o'clock at night when most sort of
internet traffic is just in Australia it
would be different again okay be
interesting if you got some result and
just tracked it according to the time of
day very very very interesting